بورت السودان صباحا
على بعد 850 كم نحو الشرق تتكئ المدينه
على ساحل البحر الاحمر
خلافا لموقعها الاستراتيجي بدات الانظار
تتجه نحوها كمدينه لا تقل اهميه عن
العاصمه الخرطوم عن كثب ظل محمد الحسن
شجيره الباحث في شؤون شرق السودان يتابع
تداعيات ما يحدث في الخرطوم على واقع
مدينه بورسودان بالنسبه اليه فان المدينه
مهيئه للتعامل مع المتغيرات الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه والاداريه في البلاد مؤهله من
ناحيه الاقامه من ناحيه الاقتصاد نحت
التجاره من ناحيه البنيات التحتيه بلدان
مؤهله تكون المدينه
الاداريه الاولى بعد الخرطوم طيب عندها
مطار دولي وعندها ميناء مطيله على كل هذا
الساحل
تكتسب بار سودان اهميتها من كونها تستوعب
الميناء البحري الرئيسي في البلاد كما ظلت
خلال الاسابيع الماضيه المنفذ الاهم
لاجلاء رعايه دول الاجنبيه من السودان
جراء الاوضاع الامنيه
هنا مطار بورتسودان الدولي بقرار من مجلس
الوزراء السوداني اصبح احد المطارات
المحدده لاستقبال المساعدات الانسانيه
الدوليه من مطار يستقبل عددا قليلا من
الطائرات اضحى بسبب الحرب امام واقع جديد
المطار
يعني كيف نفسه على المتغيرات دي بيجينا
نتعامل مع كل انواع الطائرات يعني حتى
الطائرات العسكريه من طراسيس 17 هي طيران
ضخمه جدا نقله عسكريه المطار قدر يوفر لها
المساحات الزمنيه ويوفر لها
الاطفاء والانغاز اللي تحتاجيه ولا اقدر
الليزر حصل الكارثه
في الاستقرار الامني الذي تشهده المدينه
جعل وزارات ومؤسسات رسميه تباشر مهامها من
بورتسودان فالمدينه ورغم الوضع الامني ما
تزال موانئها البحريه تستقبل السلع
الاستراتيجيه والمواد البترونيه
بتامين من الاقوات المسلحه
للولايات نحن شايفين في مشكله كبيره الان
نزيد في حجم المعادله البتروليه تدخل
الموسم الزراعي لمن الهواجس الان شغلانه
الان متحركه بصوره ممتازه الظرف
الاستثنائي الذي تمر به البلاد فرض واقعا
جديدا على مختلف المدن الاف الاسري لجات
بسبب الحرب الى بورسودان والعديد من
الوزارات الاتحاديه وسفارات استانفت
نشاطها من هنا ما يجعل المدينه الساحليه
امام اختبار صعب للتعامل مع كل هذه
المتغيرات نزار الب غداوي العربيه مدينه
بورسودان شرقيه السودان لمتابعه
المزيد برامج
والقصص للاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات